what is going on everybody and welcome
to another
sentex tankers episode and uh what we're
going to be doing is continuing
to um create our
automatic transcriber i suppose
uh with the idea of recording audio
files transcribing them and then saving
them so we can use them
for text to speech training so where we
left off
we could press a key to begin recording
we can uh break to stop the recording we
save it to output.wave
uh and now what we want to do is
take that uh transcribe that file show
it to the console and then make the
decision
is that a good transcription and if so
we will save that
prop you know to some data directory and
then we'll have
um a tsv file where we have like file
name
tab transcription and then we can use
that to train
a text-to-speech model with my voice so
um we are saving that file now we need
to transcribe that file so
uh the first test will be to see if
it transcribes so the actual
transcription is that is already done
from jarvis so we can do transcribe file
dot pi and what we want to do here
is just simply
test that file so we're going to need
server
and then audio file so um
i think i'm just going to make the
command down here first just in case
there is something we need to modify in
a little bit
so python 3 uh transcribe
underscore filed up hi the server
is dgx-a100 dash
oh my god port 5051
and then finally uh audio file is
output dot weave wav
okay now we'll come over here open and
tweminal
make it bigger and pasta that in
moment oh
maybe we don't have a good recording
let's um
okay
do we not have a good recording
oh no whatever i have last is not a good
recording here
um
so what was that python 3 tts data set
create
uh i don't think it's actually recording
yet
we need to fix this i think yeah that
wasn't recording i need to fix
that's a little confusing testing
testing one
two three okay break
and break again and
i guess we'll see did that create a file
it did
of what is a proper size let's try the
transcription
what
dang it
um that's not what i said
uh let's listen to the file testing
testing one
two three okay i'm not sure you guys can
hear that very well on the mic
because it's like a the way i've got it
set up is it just takes noises from this
direction
um but that audio file sounds good
so toaster tourist toaster tourists
that's okay that's not what i said and
we've seen the transcriptions work
pretty well so that's curious
curious indeed huh
okay um so uh
the first question i would have is like
the sampling rate possibly
um but that would be a huge bummer if i
have to use some sort of really low one
um so here they're grabbing the sample
rate
and the way they're determining it is to
get the frame rate so that bodes well
for for us
hmm
they don't really set anything else here
or show any expectations i guess
the next thing i would check is the
transcribe mic
live where is our directory
oh i've moved it okay
um okay transcribe
a mic so we'll open this one
okay so they are using a rate of 16 000.
i guess
16 000 doesn't sound as good as 44. i
wouldn't want to
hear a text-to-speech with that rate i
don't think
it just doesn't sound as good so it's
kind of a bummer hopefully that's not it
like if you're just trying to do speech
recognition or transcribe
then i understand sixteen thousand would
be good enough so hopefully
we're not gonna get boxed into that um
hmm the only other thing i
see here oh check this out let's see
formats pi audio in 16 and i think
that's what we're using right yep yep
uh and then channels one now i wouldn't
expect
channels i mean i guess it could be
channels i hope it's channels and not
rate
let's uh let's let's start with what we
hope it is
rather than what we hope it is not so
we'll set channels to one
and let's re-record
and in fact before we re-record let us
fix
what i think is broken um press c
that's okay there hold on let me think
about this
here we want to say yellow
press c to record
okay save that over here um
okay press c to record testing testing
one
two three okay saved the file will break
out of here
let us make sure the file is here it is
hear it testing one two
three sounds good even if you can't hear
it i
assure you it sounded good
finally please testing too
yes okay so we get to keep our
our sampling rate that's good very good
happy about that
um you know if we needed to lower it for
texas speech
like i think i think the lj speech data
set is actually 22 050.
it's always easy to sample down right or
sample to a smaller sample
essentially but up sampling is very
difficult so that's exciting glad we can
do that
um okay so uh
so now what um
now we begin um a hack job
um i think step one is
to transcribe
file um i think we're gonna copy this so
we don't lose the good one
because this is probably going to get a
little ugly
transcribe file uh two and in fact let's
do
two dots so it's easier for me to get
tab complete
open this up um the first thing we wanna
do is we wanna
simplify this a little bit uh listen
print loop what are you doing there
okay so this just prints out the results
and essentially it looks like what we're
interested in is this right here
like this is the one this is the answer
so
i think we can comment listen print loop
out we don't need it
and in fact i'm going to remove that
line
then i am going to
i guess i'll cut that we'll delete that
momentarily
we'll error if we don't delete it so
that's fine um
we will do this idx what are we doing
with idx
idx idx where are you using idx
what are you doing with idx
where is idx easier what
what is this wow
what is this cryptic variable you've
left for me okay
i've no idea what that's for so it's out
of here
next four response in responses if not
response dot results then we continue
well we probably want to continue the
loop so that's fine results equals
response dot results zero
okay that's fine if not results dot
alternative if what
maybe there's like maybe that means
there's no
i don't know that's confusing
uh transcript we grab our transcript
if show intermediate we're we don't want
to see that so i'm going to
and then boom
and there you have a hack job
centex certified save cool
all right this is looking good um
so we want to run the same thing and
just do two so
i'm gonna do this i am going to copy
the parms here that we passed or the
args
and we're going to instead say python3
to dot
yay for tab complete pasta boom
did we not delete we didn't
i said it was gonna happen and it
happened uh
okay again
looking good looking good now why did we
get
um oh this is what we want uh
can we just print transcript
like that i'm not sure we need the other
uh stuff there
man we're winning we're making moves
boys
and girls we have like i think i'm up to
12 percent i haven't looked in a little
bit but uh actually
my female audience is growing um
okay so let's see
okay so what we want to do is we're
going to hack job this
to our main file
uh we don't need uh
how do i want to do this this is this is
like always the part where like my
my brain cpus max out
because i want to merge these i know we
could probably like sub process
call and then get the output but we are
already
my fear is that the reason the recording
and by the time you guys see this video
you might have already responded in my
previous video but i don't know the
answer to why we couldn't record
and do the key press thing and my fear
is that as we run this program it's
going to
muck that up so i don't really want to
subprocess it that would be a valid way
i'm sure
and if someone wants to clean this up
after it's done
have at it but i think i'm just going to
butcher
[Laughter]
and just destroy this code so here we go
uh first we're going to copy pasta the
imports
boom we got some double imports in there
i'm not worried about it right now
i want to know does it work that's it
i know it's ugly it's not going to
github okay we are going to keep the
license just in case it winds up there
uh at some point but i don't plan to
share this file
not in this state so um
okay oh so we got the imports
we do not need the args we are not going
to use args
and we're going to fix all of this
shortly so
this code is going to
i hope you can't hear my dog snoring in
the background if you can sorry
um
[Music]
let's see um
i guess i'm going to take this
and we don't need that chunk i don't
think but basically
it's at this point that we have an
output.wav file
and we're going to do this because it's
a hack job
and we're going to pasta this in we are
going to now
tabulate delete
get rid of this rx.audio file this will
be uh output.with
wav um args.server
uh i kind of want to like make that a
constant i'm gonna throw server there
come up to here and
soyva is gonna be d d g x eight yes
thank you
fantastic um
cool do we have any other args that are
gonna bite us in the
rear i don't none yet so that's all this
um is generator yes generator
is used we will toss
generator
and then this i suppose we could take
this come over here
boom beautiful beautiful
i know it's not i promise i'll clean it
i'm not gonna clean it okay
does it work i'm gonna wager it doesn't
but we're gonna find out together where
is my console
oh it's over here it's cool
[Music]
oops uh oh uh oh
we got a problem i pressed c nothing
happens
well that's interesting if
e
oh you know what
that's hilarious let's see if this isn't
the problem
oh okay hold on oh my goodness that was
the problem
we did it we got the transcription
okay so what was the problem i was
pressing the c key
but caps lock was on thus uh it wasn't a
lowercase c
string e what if we do this let's
so we don't run into that one again that
was hilarious
save let's come back up that the
transcription worked i'm so happy
i'm so happy uh
testing testing one two three
testing testing one two three boom ah
yes okay we're making some good progress
here
this is wonderful this is wonderful so
okay we have done a lot of hacking
but it's working it's working um
[Music]
let's just say beginning video code here
not to be confused with syntax code
and then video code done okay um
i just don't want you guys taking credit
for my work uh
so
what now so we have our transcript
if we like it we print okay so we print
transcript
so we better have one so after the end
of this
loop we'll come down yeah
now okay
now we need to display the transcript
and so we print the transcript
and then we want to do
another one of these i think can we have
a loop
one of these loops within a loop is the
next
question so
if e we are all
my head's going to explode on this one
um
[Music]
i might be making a silly silly mistake
here
um
so because after this loop we would want
to stop
right like this loop these these will go
on forever
and we would want to stop
so first let's just let's try to gate
the saving of a file
i don't know if this is going to work
son of
a what's the problem
for response print trent if
resp is final so at this point we have
our transcript what was the
what are you whining about line 156 you
don't like
oh oh my gosh how did i miss that
i just realized my camera is gone
okay fix the camera and uh we are back
in action
so where we left off uh we just had to
tab over
um this nonsense and
now we wish to
run that again and see if this works so
proceed to record
this is a recording test
this is a recording test good uh
what do we what what
did we not um oh
okay so we didn't add anything uh to
save it so write or to say
okay press c but if we press c it will
save the file right now that's just text
but we'll add the functionality shortly
cool save file
and then it's press c to record again so
let's test that
testing another recording
fantastic i love it okay this just makes
me so excited
um okay so what we want to do
is uh print the transcript and then what
we want to say
is print c to save
uh okay green
um or make this i don't know
yellow
press c to well i guess we make it a
lower case i guess it doesn't matter
press c
to save we fix that press c to save
um or
um
i don't know what to say i don't know
what to press to like
forget about it um
i don't know we'll say t
or t to skip
okay that's good enough and
or t to skip uh
yes okay so then
so if string e is c we save the file and
then we break
and then if it is th
we'll print red
skipping saving this and
moving on okay we'll save that
and um
okay we'll save that and let me check
something real quick make sure this
camera doesn't flake out on me again
cool
um
okay so then one oh don't forget the
break yikes
uh okay so now we want to save the file
so to save the file we will add a new
directory we'll call that
data and then we're going to come up to
the
tippity top and we'll just assume we're
going to start with
uh uh
[Music]
file name 100 000.
oh that won't make sense later so now
come down here uh c to save so then
here's where we'll actually
want to save it so uh do we have os
imported
no we have every other import except for
os
so we'll come down here and we should
get away with this just an os system
call right
so so if we want to save it it's os dot
system
and we will make this an f string we
will copy
output.wav to
will this work this may or may not work
we'll test it first and see but this
might not work
data slash file whatever file name was
dot wav
and then we will do uh file name
plus eq plus equals one save
um what did we do with our console
here this cool
testing testing one two three
c to save save the file
okay and let's see if it did
feels good feels good okay
so now the problem is we already have
that and we don't want to manually
address that every single time so
but also we want to file name plus
equals one
we want to with open
uh data slash
uh transcriptions
transcriptions dot tsv with open data
transcription
uh we want to append as f we want to
f dot write and we want to write the
following f string
we want the
file name but it's also dot wav
and then we want a tab
and then we want the transcription
or transcript transcript this
transcript and then finally we want the
new
line so we will now save that
come to our console break this
we will overwrite here in a moment
here is yet another test
looks good so we would say yes let's
save it
and here is another test
and here is another test save that and
then we'll cut here
and let's come into here we've got a um
what is this hundred thousand
hundred thousand one we now have a
transcriptions file
uh i don't really wanna open it that way
let's open it with sublime
cool we are getting so close
uh feels good feels good i love it now
the
uh next thing we would want to do is
file name let's do um
uh with uh
oh gosh i don't know files os dot
equals os dot list no
my brain is it's given up right now uh
four
f in os dot list der
data um
for f and let's see how do we want to do
this uh
because we have this what essentially
what i'm trying to do is
just in case it's not clear i want to
dynamically grab the file name
and start with a proper number rather
than having to edit this every time i
start and stop the project
because it's not like i'm going to do
them all in one sitting so
okay what if we do
oh man this is going to get tricky file
name
equals the max
i'm sorry i apologize in advance for
what is about to occur
uh the max of
int
f dot
rep replace
with nothing
into f for f in
oh my gosh i got lost this is not good f
what what is this corresponding to the
int f okay this
for f in o s dot list
or data if
if dot wav
this is so bad in f
is this acceptable is this gonna work
uh print
print file name
if that works i'm going to be so happy
uh
oh my god no that can't that's not right
that's not the one we wanted is it
oh is it because we only did two so
actually it needs to be
plus one so max
take that pep 8
[Laughter]
hey we're doing it
it's fun sometimes man to just write
stuff and not care
usually like for tutorials i would never
i can't say i would never write this
code but this is the kind of code
this is my this is my jam right here
oh god okay try so we are going to try
that but the
it might be empty who knows except
exception as e
we'll do that print
red string e because we can do that now
heck yes
why oh we're not printing it anymore um
so print um
what are our color choices what do we
get
uh red bold green can we do blue
let's let's grab blue and just see can
we get away with blue
print blue
starting at
comma file name
pull this up
args must be
wasn't that except i guess we need to
like combine it as a string well we can
probably f-string it
um f string
starting at file name
how about that beautiful starting at
that awesome so um
okay so at this point we have
uh the transcriptions working so
right i think everything is working up
to this point as we would hope
done recording right i think everything
is working at this point okay we would
save it with
c cool proceed to record again
okay here is yet another transcription
beautiful uh c to save awesome
and then c to record again okay here is
yet another recording that this time
we're going to skip
oh we need to carry with a press c to
record
press c to record again um okay
so we'll come down here skipping moving
on
print green
uh
cool so that should solve that and let's
make sure we didn't get
okay here's yet
okay um i think that's actually good
enough
i mean there's probably some little
stuff that i'm going to
change and fix over time um i still
don't really like the idea of control c
to like stop the recording that's kind
of annoying um
the other issue that might come up is
the click clack of
keys uh at the end of the transcription
while i do control c here is yet another
transcription right so there is a
there's a click right at the end because
i'm pressing the control c
uh we don't want that because that will
come up
in the um in the text-to-speech
uh if we train a model on that uh and
that would be like really
weird um so what we want to do for that
i don't know i guess i would maybe frame
skip frame
skip set that to five
um that might be too many probably
we'll do three and what we'll do is
come down to where we save where are you
where are you here frames
[Music]
done recording uh we'll say here
uh frames equals um frames
equals frames
up to negative frame skip so that should
cut off
the last few frames let's test that
really quickly
here we go testing the frame skip
i love these transcriptions and it's so
fast i just
i cannot get over how fast this stuff
works
so happy we'll save it uh we'll break it
um here we go testing the frame skip
awesome come over here uh play that
here we go testing the frame skip
right and there was no click at the end
perfect
uh so that means we kind of need to
delete these
originals unfortunately um
so yeah i'll do that so we don't want to
have any
of the bad data i don't know why here
we'll close this
um yeah okay uh
that's good that's good spots to stop i
think that's a pretty good
i can't think of anything else there
might come like little tweaks and stuff
that i make and i'm totally gonna clean
up this file i mean it's so messy
how could anybody work with that uh
other than that um i think it's actually
ready so maybe be on the lookout
for some uh syntax text-to-speech but
this is gonna take a long time to be
honest i mean you need so many files
and so much data but this is a good
start this will make it
relatively easy as easy as it gets i
suppose
to like make this kind of a data set so
um
cool i'm excited to see if this actually
works what other problems i
i hit along the way but i have high
hopes this is looking good
um questions comments suggestions
whatever feel free to leave them below
i think my biggest pain point now is the
control c i would rather not
do that so if someone has an idea of
you know what's causing that feel free
uh to
make a suggestion i can't really decide
if i want to put this on github or not
it's so ugly um and it really is
it's a meshing of a bunch of code that
isn't mine so uh
yeah i'm not really sure i'm gonna put
it up but um yeah let me know if you
have an idea of like something i can
change
to uh get this to work
uh anyway that's all see you guys in the
next video
you